morgan hoffman with e.t canada hey riz
how you doing hey good to meet you nice
to meet you too uh i know you celebrated
your birthday yesterday so i wanted to
know
if you did anything fun you know the
honest truth is
um i went to the academy museum oh wow
over here in l.a which is super super
cool it's amazing to see all those
different filmmakers being celebrated
and just a history of cinema over here
in hollywood and all the breakthroughs
that we made over the years so it's
pretty inspiring actually check it out
that's cool did you get to eat any cake
i ate so much cake i'm not usually a
sweet tooth kind of guy but yeah being
brought cake all day you can't say no
right right you have to eat it
exactly
amazing
when i was reading uh before you even
signed on for this film uh that you
pitched yourself that you really wanted
this role what was it about this project
that
you were excited to be a part of it's
just so unusual
you know i can't think of that many
films like this it's got all those
thrills and spills of the sci-fi kind of
action
movies got the imagination of those kind
of movies but it's hard it's about
relationships a father-son story it's
about family you know it's about
characters so that balance is something
that i saw michael pierce do so well in
his last film uh beast and now
uh and once i saw that just blew my mind
and i straight away just kind of like
got in touch with my agent said what's
this guy doing next when i found out
yeah you're right i stalked him
basically you know i was just like
texting him i was um
you know
uh calling him up getting friends to
call him up meet up with him for coffee
and i was just like dude i gotta do this
film and he was like okay
freaking me out a little bit just to
take some space and think about this but
luckily it worked he's like i just
wanted to stop here take it
um i think it was really cool for me to
see you play a dad on screen i believe
that's your first time playing a father
on screen you're so good was that a
little daunting at first for you just
being that that was the first time
well you know it was something i was
really scared or one of the reasons i
did the role i always like try and do
things that scare me a little bit
and i was terrified of playing a dad i
thought will they buy me as a dad will
they accept me you know what will our
relationship be like and then i realize
that's exactly what my character malik
is thinking in the film because he
hasn't seen his kids for a couple of
years so he's also going to be
having those same insecurities and
anxieties and i think when you start
thinking the same thoughts as a
character
i think that's a good sign you know so i
just thought okay lean into it and
luckily man they you know they took me
under their wing those guys are running
the show and uh they're amazing they're
both so so talented
such
kind of
glowing spirits you know it's just
there's an infectious energy being
around
um kids like that you know yeah they're
just so natural i was just so impressed
by kind of the dynamic of all three of
you um what did your family think when
they they watched you play dad
um
i mean i think they just really liked
the film to be honest um
yeah a bunch of my family came to uh is
screening a london film festival and
they all told me honestly it's their
favorite film of mine i've done
uh huge so i was like wow that's that's
really cool so they were just really
into it like i said i think this film
really does have that kind of hit so
many different buckets you know like i
said it's got the action it's got that
thriller thing it's got lots of plot
twists so you're going to be kept
guessing but it's just got so much heart
at the center of it it's about you know
trying to keep your family safe in an
uncertain world and
i think a lot of people can relate to
that right now yeah
and it has octavia spencer
exactly
so mike drop yeah exactly
amazing so nice getting to talk to you
and happy belated birthday thank you
thanks morgan